and a one two one two three foot where's
your chords play me the chords sorry I
haven't had the banjo out I moved now I
came back into the studio and these all
of these instruments are out of key do
it I don't care you don't care no
they're helpful yo he is darling
I didn't want to do it but anyway
welcome back to the corridor cast today
we've got a select crew here amongst
amongst us men among boys that would say
we've got we've got Nico Nico say hi hi
we've got Sam Sam say hi hi and we've
got Wes Wes say hi say hi Wow so we're
gathered here today for another episode
and we thought you know there's been a
lot going on the last few weeks and but
instead of talking about necessarily
just the the distinct points of what's
happened because you've all you all know
what's going on I don't need to preface
it I'd like to talk spend today talking
about what where do we go from here you
know how do we what do we yeah we all
know what's happening on the outside but
we have to figure out what's happening
happening on the inside and also but
also like how does this play into our
role as creators you know because you
know you could talk about oh well they
should do this or they should do that
and this this this ambiguous today yeah
but you know let's yes I mean every
knows you know that we have a platform
with viewers and it's generally a thing
someone's watching this was a big social
movement too
you know there's not gonna say yeah
there's a pressure to do something um
you guys feel pressured well regardless
of how we feel like there is that
pressure I mean even if you want to do
something it doesn't mean that the
pressure doesn't exist to do something
either I I feel the pressure mostly just
because I feel like there's I mean I
can't escape it everything I see right
now is people basically saying the whole
like if you're not saying something
you're basically and it's kind of like
like what what do you say what am I
gonna do I just retweet the same hashtag
is that like the am I good now like and
I that's what I've been really hesitant
to dive deep into it because personally
I mean our whole YouTube career like
everything we're trying to do here is
like we don't try and yeah you know
there's the bottle flip challenges this
team trees thing it's like we you know
like I think some of these things are
cool these movements are sweet and but
it's in a weird way the way a social
media kind of takes these ideas and
twists them they no longer feel like
they're like the genuine it doesn't feel
like it's a genuine thing to do or say
is the activity of the week yeah it's
like becomes a trend like yeah clicking
a retweet button doesn't like really you
know it's weird it's complicated so not
fill you that's why we're here
yeah I think I think there is you know
three groups of people kind of like
there's the people that are like you
know serious about this movement there's
people that are just hopping on for a
trend for the time hoping it passes over
and there are some people that really
are against this and I think if you lay
in the middle you it's important to be
empathetic you know like all right this
thing makes me feel awkward all right
you know let's address why it makes you
feel awkward okay what are these people
actually saying you know so like you
know being empathetic is like one of the
biggest steps and you know not being
afraid to ask questions I think is is is
a big thing so I can understand where
you're coming from which is kind of like
a simple retweet is that enough and I
don't think you know when the retweet is
not natural for you and it you know
retweet is almost kind of dissing
genuine to the whole movement in general
you know it's like like how do you feel
about it like be honest about how you
feel I think that's okay you know and be
open to have those like we said in the
video those views channeling
I think it also comes with like a
tremendous around a research like just
the movement in general I think the
bottom line is equality but the black
lives matter
you know hashtag our movement whichever
one you're going with because I feel
like there's there may be two different
agendas going but I feel like with
acknowledging black people are upset or
feel as if they have been just
segregated and and targeted is is
important because it doesn't like this
movement starts with them and then it
goes on to other races so like I think
it's important to support it be with it
and understand like this is this
movement right here is not going to
change anything tomorrow or the next day
this is a movement that changes things
ten twenty thirty years from now you
know for you guys kids you know to be in
an environment that is like just an
equal playing field for everyone where
we don't we genuinely don't see color we
see the human race you know so this is
the trans movement this is the gay
movement this is black people Asian this
is everyone's movement but right now
it's specifically focused on black
people because we're you know pretty
much set up an assistant before front
yeah I mean you know dude it's it's
crazy you know like it's made me just
kind of take a step back and I'm
learning so much about my own culture
that I didn't even know that's good like
you have the racial facet of it but then
you also have the police and government
accountability facet which is frankly
another thing that I kind of wish it
would still stand the spotlight a little
bit more this whole sense of like I'm
I'm proud to PC people demanding that
the government be held accountable and
they answer to the people that's
supposed to serve yeah like I said I'm
really happy to see that with people
saying like these are the rules you guys
have passed why the [ __ ] aren't you guys
enforcing these rules yes you know it's
like you now you see like the the D
of LA like you know putting assault
charges on a cop like you know assaulted
like so homeless guy it's like you know
oh now you're getting to it now you have
to get yeah you know and like it's such
a small token gesture but like yeah you
know it's I'm glad to see people waking
up to that and realizing like that the
government is supposed to serve the
community the government's not supposed
to serve profit interest the
government's not supposed to serve money
we have all our businesses for that we
have the whole free-market side of
America for that like the government
serves the people and it should be held
accountable din to the people holding to
the people and mean there's people that
work hard in the government there's a
lot of people that go into the
government for an easy job yeah and an
easy paycheck so one thing that has been
tough for me I guess to recognize
throughout all this is you know there's
a lot of different philosophies that go
into how next steps should be taken and
I want to make sure that as an
individual like this if I'm gonna say
hey I support this or that that I'm I'm
I'm supporting something that I feel
like is genuinely going to help and I
what one of my biggest concerns is that
all of this is gonna just lead to
government and mandates like
heavy-handed sort of like bludgeoning
tool type policy that's just bang bang
and that's my concern is like is now you
know you've got you've got people paying
attention you've got now people ready
and willing to do things to take
progress and take steps forward but I'm
concerned that the next steps are gonna
be like okay like you know we're gonna
it's like mandating the minimum wage you
know but on like a way away larger scale
a way larger scale you know and the idea
obviously the complaint that you always
hear behind you can't mandate the
minimum wage is that you know there's a
certain like you can't just come in and
say well this is how much this is worth
and you can't just also come in and say
well business you need to you need to do
this you need to and that's my concern
is like that it's it's not gonna
actually happen and in a fundamental way
it's they're gonna try to make it happen
from a way that's top-down rather than
focusing on like the actual uplifting of
like disenfranchised communities yeah
yeah because that's and that's my my
thing too on it which I've really spoken
too much about it or posted much or like
because like you know I don't know the
the answers cuz I feel like right now
the way I see most of the discussion
going seems really one-dimensional when
I kind of feel like it's you know 10
dimensional at this point where it's
like you have two factors here there's
like the the racial injustice side of
things and then you have the police side
of things and then the third part of
things is the concept of you know being
in this pandemic and quarantine and all
the stuff that's you know people staying
at home and losing jobs and bah-bah-bah
and all that stuff being like a big wave
that just pushes it forward so
everything is kind of being amplified
because of that you know it's like in a
funny way you know these are the kind of
this is the the rights we're seeing
right now are kind of the riots people
were predicting when they started
lockdowns and like we're imagining oh
it's the end of the world people are
losing the jobs the government shutting
everything down people are gonna go nuts
because of that and it's like yep they
did you know they did yeah and so that
being said like it wasn't necessarily
that specific reason why things went
crazy but it's it's that way that day
isn't the way that game that kind of
helps lift it all up and so you know and
then back to the racial justice thing
it's like it's not just about law
enforcement here in my opinion it's not
just about like the way people are
treated when they are either like
apprehended or confronted by police but
it's the whole situation of how they get
there in the first place with you know
the idea of like inequality with like
the economic outcomes for people of
different races and things like that you
know like how how level is the playing
field so to speak the playing field has
been you know set against black people
from the very beginning yeah I mean and
that's you know like this this system
you know unfortunately it's you know
we've abolished slavery in like what
1865 and but reintroduced it in the
prison system and then you have the
government and the presidents that
signed these bills you know this this
prison reform bill that pretty much
through blanketed you know different
documents that the ninety-four crime
goes the one that spiked the prison
population it actually snow right in
with Reagan okay
and then I don't know the specifics
speak but I'm trying to it's been an
upward spike from from the 80s on or
from the six did you see the John Oliver
episode that he did last week it was is
it was a really good synopsis of like
how we got here at least with respect to
the police and and this whole thing and
I don't really recommend people we'll
put a link in the description I'd really
recommend people watch it because I mean
for example you know you want to talk
about that that institutionalized stuff
and you know for a long time I wasn't
necessarily a believer me neither of
that and I wasn't necessarily a believer
of like well you know it's been it's
been a hundred and sixty years since
slavery you know which honestly isn't
that long but also at the same time as a
long time and but at the same time you
know the the house that my parents
bought in in Stillwater Minnesota when
when I went off to college
there was still a covenant in there that
no one bothered to remove because
obviously everyone was it was a scofflaw
you know as a scoff covenant no one took
it seriously but it was the the covenant
was saying that section of tonight
somewhat scofflaw means ya scofflaw home
I'm hearing words that I don't
understand the full meanings of a scoff
covenant are we talking about it like a
religious no no sorry that's like lawyer
speak so a a scofflaw is a term
for a law that is written down on a book
as in some legislative body decided to
pass it or some governing body of some
kind decided to pass it but because it's
so ridiculous or people read it and they
go so so then what's the Covenant aspect
the Covenant is just another word for a
clause or gateway agreement oh so so
during the time the house was built is
that reason why covenant just real quick
tangent the reason why covenant has
become synonymous with like Old Religion
is because the contract between God and
the people of Abraham is it was a
contract God said I'll do this you do
that they called it a covenant but a
covenant it actually means agreement
alright so back up a step in so so the
house back to the house yeah this house
was part of a school the school was torn
down in 1941 in 1941 they wrote an
agreement for all the property owners
and one of the one of the lines in the
property was only white people huh you
couldn't sell the property to anybody of
color and I scoffed at it when I read it
because I was like that's still on there
like you know obviously like it was
something that no one followed or even
considered to even look at it was like
deep within the the language of this but
you know perhaps a good metaphor for for
some of this stuff it's it's deep within
the language you have people have
something we've forgotten about it a
little bit but at the same time
sometimes here and there if you think
it's all the way gone it's still on the
covenant yes right exactly yeah a house
that I inherited that I then sold yeah
yeah Wow
yeah so that I mean like that's that's
that's one of my biggest things you know
like with this whole situation there's
so many different like laws and you know
just kind of redirections hidden within
these contracts and unfortunately you
know it's set up against people of color
like you know our whole history has you
know when we when we go to school we
learn history we learn about American
history and then you gloss over one
month of black history you gloss over
that [ __ ] but in reality black history
is American is exactly yeah it's you
know so like I don't understand
you know and a lot of people you know a
lot of black people don't under don't
know their history it would be amazing
to know about our history and that's one
of the things that this is kind of
sparked inside me to find out more about
my history I'm like what yeah I didn't I
didn't know a lot of this stuff that's
so important and and that that but I'm
so glad to hear that because that's like
honestly but you think about it from and
you think back hundreds of years and you
think about the fact that there was this
slave trade and that this this this act
of trading people ripped people from
their homes and raped them of their
culture literally and then brought in
that and then it's like you know it you
you can you put that up against the
other races who did not have that
happening and oh that idea of like
passing on generational knowledge
passing on generational wealth you all
the sudden took it and you completely
removed it from the scenario and then
you didn't allow it to be brought forth
yeah for 400 years
well we're only at that point now we're
only at that point now where it's like
yes like there's yeah there's a there's
a spark that's waking up in people which
is is great you know and I love it and I
feel like that's the empathetic part
about it it's just kind of like alright
this is what our ancestors did there's
you know the white side and this is what
this is what our ancestors went through
there's the black side and out of that
you know through that oppression black
people inherently created culture their
own culture you know from nothing from
from oppression from being held back
from not being able to read learn on the
right you know participate you know we
have some of the best inventions today
that was created by black people but
they couldn't patent it because they
weren't allowed so you think about the
cell phone the elevator you know like
it's it's insane and you know that's
what makes me so passionate about you
know where we're at now what we're doing
now and how we can contribute to I think
I think the best way to do things is to
educate people like that's something
that you can take away from nobody your
education and if we share that education
that is how we you know progress forward
you know that is how we help that next
generation you know that's a step away
from DNA is the one way to pass
information from one generation to the
next
yeah really the only species that can
pass on knowledge from the next and
evolve differently so let's talk about
this let's talk about this idea of like
passing on this this knowledge and you
know there's always this phrase that
often gets attributed to I guess how do
I say this you know often to like
conservative White's
who are like saying well you know the
world's free now no one's a slave now go
and do something you know and so let's
remove a little bit of the like negative
context and the ignorant context that
comes with that statement
mm-hm but let's talk about like well
with with the way that the world is
currently like what are some things that
everybody can focus on for this sort of
knowledge and success to be passed on
and to be learned and to you know like
it's kind of hard to say what everyone
should focus on because you know we're
all on our own individual journey that's
true
late but I guess yeah I don't know like
that's that's the thing that I'm always
looking for within this is like you know
like what can I do well you have
legislative skills you know you're a
lawyer you you know I mean like there I
think passing on like how people can
approach this you know in a legal way
without you know without being doing the
negative things like I feel like I'm
powerless in terms of like hey going up
to the government and be like hey listen
on page 10 of this document this
happened you know I don't that's not my
field but there is someone out there
that is their field that maybe it'll
spark something in them to be like
alright guys we need to come together we
both we all have law degrees this is how
we need to attack the legislation in
this state or approach the mayor in this
state I
think for myself it'll be research
passing on knowledge you know like
that's genuinely what I can do but I
want to pass it on in a cool way I don't
want to be so you know like you know
sometimes when adults speak to you it's
hard to listen like I've heard my whole
life you know just about black history
and it's like oh cool yeah you know like
it's but it's been gloss over Martin
Luther King changed everything and
everything's great now that's right you
know that's that's honestly I walked as
I did a lot he did do a lot he did do a
lot but then there was you know Malcolm
X who had opposing you know arguments
with him you know and just understanding
you know just the depths of these two
men and what they went through and who
they're you know what they're
representing is is huge but you know
there was not just them there was a
whole other movement behind them in in
different areas and you know the only
way we were able to get things out there
was by passing on information it's a
television they were televising these
things and video recording it that's how
that was getting out there now that we
have these cell phones it's just like a
big spotlight on brutality in general
you know like you know the prison
reforms like that were signed back in
the 80s were specifically to target the
underprivileged and black neighborhoods
they literally section off areas to
funnel money you know it's a fun schools
here and not fund areas over here you
know so we get the shitty books we get
the teachers I don't care we you know we
get the low paying job so it's it's a
system that's set up for failure and now
if you rise out of that figures great
why would someone want to do that
slavery like you know I mean like this
is like where did you go to school where
was your childhood spent my childhood
was spent in Japan I grow yeah all that
stuff yes so you have to dodge that
thankfully I not really not really I
feel like you know I grew up in a
melting pot of students which was just a
a bunch of different cultures and you'd
have you know different race relations
but I guess I guess in
did I was able to dodge like any of like
the poverty-stricken areas because we
were sheltered on a military base yeah
but on this military base we learned
American history and the greatest people
were you know George Washington Abraham
Lincoln Christopher Columbus the Nina
Pinta and Santa Maria but no black
people I didn't know about George
Washington Carver I mean I heard about
him but it wasn't a big thing Frederick
Douglas it wasn't a big thing and now
I'm like holy [ __ ] these guys help
change the world you know in a positive
way you know even dealing with the
oppression so that's I mean I feel like
being able to spread that information as
well as you know Americans but like
really be honest about like you know the
[ __ ] that these guys did you know like a
lot of these guys were like rapists
you know pillagers conquerors liars you
know and it didn't you know like that's
not what's told us yeah you know that's
that one is tough for me because it's
there's always a there's always a
tendency no matter who the person is in
history but there's always a tendency to
look on a person of history with with
the lens of today standards exactly and
it's like well yeah of course George
Washington owned slaves you know he was
he was of that ilk at that time yeah and
that's what you were supposed to do and
that's what that's what he did that's
what the history is at that time yes
yeah so it's I don't know how you take
that one but that one I never I don't
know I never agreed with the the
preposition that we should we should
uphold today's standards on to people of
the past yeah - I mean honestly wants to
get into that line of thinking basically
everyone who existed or sorry everyone
who was born more than I guess 40 50
years ago was a horrible person because
either they're yes
sexist somehow they're racist somehow
they buy into some sort of thing that
goes against our current cultural mores
culture evolves and yeah yeah ideally
and that's part of it but I mean it's
not that I disagree yes
early saying that isn't good and if they
existed today with those standards
obviously that's a different story
yeah human beings a desire to view the
whole world in black and white and you
know see the world through good guys and
bad guys and and you know simplify
things but labels on things because
that's just how human beings are but you
know you're never going to have an
accurate view of reality if you have to
compartmentalize everything into good
bad you know it's like sure nothing
works that way yeah yeah and you can
make your judgments and things by all
means but like everybody's going to have
shades of gray like you know World War
two Nazis bad America good guess what
America still killed civilians in World
War two yeah kebab Suresh Mike
surrendering soldiers the other day
there was this one hundred and seven
year old World War two veteran and it
was filmed in 2003 and he was born in
1895 Wow and he was telling the story
about how he was sitting on a beach and
the guy next to him literally just got
shot in the head and dropped and then so
he took cover and there's a sniper in
the area so eventually they found the
sniper and they just they just shot him
while he was in the tree and he just
fell out of the tree dead like they
didn't take time did like to ask him to
surrender they didn't take you know and
that because that was what you do yeah
that's what exactly because in that
context in the middle of World War two
at that time that was how you dealt with
that problem yeah and you know it's
today you know I'm sure if that happened
it would be a different story
maybe not yeah well they made they're
just calling aerial strikes yeah but I
think the lesson I think the takeaway
it's like if you're trying to view
history is through a good and bad like
you're not gonna actually learn history
because history is just it's forces its
power plays it's you know you got to
kind of step back and like intellect the
omnipresent universal lens so I'm like
we're looking at history of just like
here's creatures on this planet
interacting here's the forces at play
that have lead to these results yeah and
you can see that you know I was reading
up on the presidents
the other day this is such a nerdy Jake
thing but like I was reading up on the
presidents and I was reading the White
House's official like description of who
ulysses s grant was it was like
basically like he was okay but he wasn't
that good it's basically the synopsis I
was like wow they really are honest
about these old guys they say that about
like Clinton it's like too new that
one's a lot more political yeah
throughout time does that huh yeah it
makes it like okay to like step back and
look at things 50 dollar bill and he did
turn the Union Army around during the
Civil War
those guys were [ __ ] by the way like
the Confederates actually it's kind of
to talk about a relevant issue here like
the Confederate Army almost won the war
like two or three times and it would
have been over and and everything fell
apart after Gettysburg but basically
Grant was the guy that cracked the
Confederacy in half because they were
trying to capture Vicksburg Mississippi
mm-hm and and they like just could not
get to it it was like they'd go through
swamps and they'd go and they tried to
cut trails and they tried to come this
way and they tried to come around this
way and they like and eventually they
broke through this one area and then
they just sat outside of it for like 20
weeks until they gave up Wow yeah and
and then after that like the pharisee
split in half and then everything just
kind of like the Union Army at that
point we had become so efficient and the
war machine of like the northern
Enterprise had become so good at just
creating soldiers that they just had so
many and they just and then they'd at
that point they just picked like you
know and they'd just pick points in the
south and they'd be like let's get rid
of that one let's get rid of that town
let's get rid of that town and they just
kept doing that until the whole thing
shrunk mmm yeah
so where is the balance between
being colorblind and looking at people
for entirely for their skillset or their
character and where's the balance for
acknowledging someone's ethnicity
someone's background their upbringing
things are outside of who that person is
right in that moment because you know
you have you have that at play people
you know saying like you need to hire
for diversity okay so do you hire for
diversity or do you hire for character
do you hire for both but there's a
balance you know there's a hate that I
hate I don't personally like hire for
diversity
I did a director's program as Sony and
it was diverse directors program women
and you know other ethnicities and I
feel like that puts a target on your
back you know it labels it's a label on
top of if you're a director but you're a
diverse direct yeah and I'm like what
you never made it if you weren't right
color you know I mean yeah I haven't
made it I've been directed any
television so it's it's just like I
appreciate the sentiment
you know but I feel like if we are going
to progress forward as a human race you
know first step acknowledging yo there's
some really messed up stuff like let's
bring this history to light for everyone
to know you know of course they're gonna
people that are very upset about it
however you know being apathetic and
standing in solidarity saying you know
like today like you know this [ __ ] will
no longer fly that's great
that way we take the labels off and then
you just hire to hire you know like
you're hired hire like yo you got dope
skills you're dope come on board let's
make this happen you know that's how I
would hire you know I feel like we
literally the last hiring process we
received a thousand applications with
just names and links to where possible
submission but people can still say well
if you look at the names you won't hire
the foreign sounding ones no
I mean I I didn't oh yeah Christian
what's your middle name there you go
whoa what does that mean that's a really
cool name that's tight so anyways and
they fit all that into a language with
less less letters yeah anyways we don't
look at names yeah I think is I think is
a dope you know being here in a you know
like I really appreciate you know us
working on that video and you know at
least having a point of view you know to
just start the conversation you know I
feel like you know a lot of the comments
you know people have like different
views on it but it's interesting to see
people actually talking about stuff that
we wouldn't normally just see people
like you know point the finger at or
either be extremely racist or just
completely like I don't give a [ __ ]
about this but now they're like actually
engaging in conversation you can see it
in comments like people have opposing
views people have agreeing views people
are like why I never looked at it that
way it was great to see people making an
effort to have like rational or
respectful conversation yes you know
that's how you learned yeah I mean
everybody so eager just like once again
either to use it as your identity so
therefore you're gonna get personally
invested and anything that disagrees
with you it's an emotional thing or
you're just looking to like rile people
up so you just gonna start calling
people names and like you get so little
actual discourse of people talking to
someone else who disagrees in a
respectful way like what's yeah also I
mean it's so hard to find that these
days I was happy to see it in the
comments what you guys went the
direction you did with that piece
because it's at the moment you start
either doing like finger pointing or you
start basically telling people the
opinions they should have or telling
them what to do that's where you start
to
really enter a pretty risky territory
that I think you know we've this is why
we avoid doing these types of videos
generally what's why the politics in
politics in general because well I think
first off there's plenty of political to
YouTube channels and people want watch
political channels go watch a channel
where people dedicate their lives to
researching and studying and talking
about their opinion there's more
suitable people for that and ultimately
what in one especially when you hit a
week or two where you can't get a break
from it so to speak now like not to say
you're sick of it or whatever the point
is you know like it's good to have
something else there if you're like I
would like to hear or see something that
is not getting me like emotionally angry
and worked up and what whatever you know
what I mean like it's right it's yeah
there's there's a lot of that stuff out
there and I think it's as far as like
how I've kind of begun to perceive what
I do and what we do here I feel like
over the last few years it feels like
it's good to get political themes just
like oh yeah do this this is wrong this
person is wrong but then it's like wait
a second like there is a there is a role
to just try and be neutral in a way and
entertain people and not necessarily
push an agenda times and so I feel like
it's a good it's a good guiding line to
do that and then coming back to the
video I think it it's a it does a good
job at saying hey this is why people
feel the way they do right now and it's
and it's true it's a it's very objective
and it doesn't necessarily need to get
into and here's what you need to do
differently yeah specifically here's
here's this you know it's like it's it
is just the thought process right now I
mean that that's well that's like what
you're saying was with like you know the
knowledge so to speak and the knowledge
is learned so to speak and in everyone's
individual way so yeah
danger with the danger with identity
politics as in taking on political
viewpoints as part of your identity is
that
your viewpoints can change and they do
change that's the that's the thing that
they don't tell you for everybody who's
17 listening to this like your views
will change yeah they will you will
learn things about life you will go
through experiences and whether or not
you want to believe it
life will force you to recognize reality
for what it is
yeah and that will ultimately help Forge
and form your actual opinions about
things and I think the most important
thing attacking on to that is that your
views will be learned over time and that
you can never really sink yourself into
something that is so absolutely don't
get me wrong there are absolute truths
out there there's a few of them you know
there's a couple but beyond that like
with the way that say you want it you
want to dig your heels into like no this
is the exact problem and it needs to be
dealt with in this exact way and
anything less than this is a complete
failure when you get when you find
yourself getting to that point you know
you might want to say hey maybe there's
something else I can learn here it's
hard when you're on that train of being
like it's just this it's hard to slow
down so you have to be able to say it
surround yourself with people that are
going to challenge you people that are
gonna help you become better you know or
like see different viewpoints and that's
well that's the thing about you know
think about who your friends are and
this is something that my parents always
said and I was like what your parents
you know but it's true like you you the
people that you're around ultimately you
you absorb all this information and
culture from them and and eventually
that you you take on some of that and so
I mean that's as old as the Bible though
that's like the old thing and it's be
careful of who you're around because you
become that person or you know it's the
same as guilty by association which
ironically is part of this whole problem
I would love to see people encourage and
celebrate other people who change their
opinions upon looking at new information
more like changing your opinion is such
like such a thing to be looked
upon right now like Oh a politician
change our stance on this what a liar
what what [ __ ] loser everybody have a
conversation and change your mind after
a conversation or research or fighting
spineless we're gonna have to mark this
one as explicit I think I think Sam for
you bro like you know I appreciate you
saying I don't know what to say and I
don't want to just retweet I think
because you're such an intellectual
person say how you really feel like why
not you know like the only people are
any gonna tell you how they feel at the
end of the day but like at least you
were honest about it at the end of the
day like yeah like boom this is how I
feel this is my stance you know I don't
you know whatever it may be
at least you told your truth then no one
could take your truth away from you yeah
as it as it exists until you learn more
things and change your opinion or don't
maybe it'll help solidify that's the
thing is sometimes sometimes more
information like it's like oh well now I
know more about this and that confirms
what I thought but that's also something
that you don't want to just do Neil
deGrasse Tyson on masterclass has had a
phrase and he said basically just google
searching the answer to all the all the
answers that you want to know is is the
most like destructive way to obtain
knowledge because all it does is give
you back information that you're looking
for it doesn't it's not like it doesn't
test it against an absolute truth like
it like you can test a scientific
problem against its physical properties
or against mathematics yeah you know
where it's like well it doesn't matter
if you don't believe that the universe
is is is here it doesn't matter if you
don't believe that the earth is round
it is so because there it is you know
yeah I'd love to talk about you know as
you see a lot of YouTube channels too
for lack of a better term like hit
pieces you know like this guy I learned
about this guy look how much of an
[ __ ] this guy is or you know
look how yeah these people are look how
wrong this became a whole genre cancels
and you know this is informed I think
you know how corridor approaches
politics in our videos as you can see we
tend to avoid politics that's not to say
we don't avoid human issues I mean a
part of storytelling is human the human
experience yeah we're always down to
talk about human issues human
experiences etc but we don't get into
the politics we don't start saying which
party yes or what is your very
educational
you know like you come you come the
corridor to be entertained and educated
I think and I feel like and if I might
walk away from a quarter video I feel
smarter you know I feel I feel smarter
did you watch the heart attack yet but
heart attack sounds amazing
no like honestly like the stories are
always well-rounded they always bring
you back you know at the end of the day
and I think that's one thing that this
channel does well so when we make in
this video that's one of the things I
was always at the forefront of my mind
like all right how does how do Sam and
Nico normally introduce videos how does
run introduce a video like I wanted that
same feeling you know especially if I'm
gonna be on the platform with you guys
and that you know I feel like that it
came across like when I look at the
other videos I'm like okay this feels
and and flows like you know the channel
is it doesn't feel forced you know it
doesn't feel like I'm trying to tell you
what to do but like it makes you think
at the end of day like okay I like that
it had a personal experience that we
talked about yeah you know it's like so
we were trying to figure this out and he
sat down we had a conversation fine so
that just happened because we had
another exam later I know it happened
literally that day multiple examples
that day it happened and I was like what
yeah that's weird I mean he was going
off to it I couldn't get my phone out
fast enough cuz I was like I was on my
one wheels like what and he's losing it
it granted
we left out the part that dude was
homeless you know and I was clear it's
like there's two halves to that I think
yeah right now we're because my first
reaction when I saw that clip was like
oh he's a crazy homeless guy he's
probably he could say anything actually
and I would be surprised with it you
know but it's also I think it's still
the underlying point of he's still
turning to it's still in ecology it's
really it you know it just shows it
proves the existence it's a it's a
weaponized word in order to you know
keep black people down you know I mean
like that'sthat's what it is it's just
weaponized verbage and he has enough
sense to pull that from wherever he was
part of being homeless you know to use
it against me you know and that's the
part where it's just like yo like let's
just listen eliminate [ __ ] like that
and that [ __ ] is that [ __ ] is what you
know this is one of the most fascinating
topics that I think exists in in like
English culture or like like speaking
culture the concept of one word that is
weaponized and is like so Kent can be so
powerful mm-hmm because you can't keep
like because you can't get rid of it
mm-hm you know what I mean yeah you know
I'm saying like what the what the hell
do you do because like like yeah like I
agree you don't like it's not in my
language I don't say it I've never even
like I'm like at most it's like the most
you can joke about it is like just
making the sound of the letter n you
know what I mean but you can't even go
past that you know what I mean it's like
it's so toxic that like it's crazy that
is so how do you deal with that other
than simply say don't say it cuz like
you're not do you just hope that in 200
years the words kind of like in a like
oh here's a history of English its
cultural like if it wins language and
then you're like oh a funny old word
they used to use you know
I mean and you're like or like the same
way you research any language like did
you know the word but ever that means
you know horse [ __ ] in in uh in Celtic
you know what I mean is it can turn into
scallywag scallywag black people is a
tournament of endearment you know that
we've embraced as a culture but anybody
else saying it it is I mean it it just
makes it triggers you know that's the
joke in like white culture is like when
somebody uses like a slang term for an
Irish like if two Irish people use a
slang term towards each other the and
the joke is always like hey you can't
say that that's our word you know it's
like a take on that yeah but there's
also its cultural I mean I guess that
there is that like sub culture
acceptance acceptance of phrases like
that that do exist and so maybe but I
mean maybe that's always it's American
culture you know like it's it's just
it's a bad time in history you know and
it was never it was not conjured up ever
as endearment it was enslavement yeah it
was right there in the last name yeah it
meant you have black skin and you're a
slave that's that's what it meant yeah
well another I think it gets mixed up in
all this too is like this is like the
quintessential thing he discovers
teenagers that words have power you know
it's like oh yeah just drop this word
and see people get pissed off right it's
like whoa cool it's like yeah words have
power it's like that's just part of the
human experience and like something you
discover you can just say a word and
skate all these different reactions out
of it and it's like you know the same
thing as banging pots and pans together
as a B and C that's something that I
didn't take seriously when I was younger
like you know like a you'd be like oh
you could say it like say anything yeah
and then but Jordan Peterson actually
has a lot of great breakdowns on like
why where words come from how words
words aren't just actually words it's
not like you're just this is the sound
yes not just this town you're literally
taking thoughts in your head
manifesting them into an audible tone
that actually has a physicality to it
and then ideally the hope is that you're
speaking truth and you're speaking
honesty and you're doing so with
goodness and then you are literally then
going out and creating that around you
and so it's not just like let's become
things exactly you're not just like and
then there's the whole physiological
response of like when you say like [ __ ]
yeah you know like I know there's
there's that whole element of language
where by saying those words like it can
literally like change your emotions like
in you're not from like a tonal sense
but like in pain okay there's like like
what is it like there's weird like like
like either like stress relieving
properties especially if you're pissed
off and saying words like that like oh
yeah yeah you get like yeah there's like
it's a whole it's a whole interior thing
that goes yeah what's the same with like
pictures it's like well those are just a
bunch of dots on a page
those are colored lights on a screen
it's like no that's a guy who got ran
over by a train just pixels man well no
they represent something yeah yeah
managing your energy is huge and
managing you know what you say is is big
because like as soon as you say it
you've spoke it into existence and that
that can affect you you you and you and
me so you know I've been spending a lot
of time in my mind and really like
concentrating on just alright what is
the what is the thoughts that I want to
produce into life you know so managing
my energy managing the words I say
managing my thoughts you know positive
versus negative like this subject it's a
hurtful subject but how can I transform
that into an educational feeling you
know so that's where I'm spending a lot
of my my energy and my mind energy at
you know because I think about all right
how's this gonna create how's this going
to affect the universe around me you
know yeah so
yeah that's crazy man it's crazy to
think about like sometimes it's too much
for me you know sometimes I'll have to
just like step back and and like turn
try to turn my mind off because if I
like you know if I focus on it too much
then sometimes I feel like I'm not as
good as just just being myself yeah you
get you can get lost at first at first I
was very angry just so upset you know I
was just like I feel I felt betrayed I
felt lied to I felt like you know like
it was kind of a confirmation for just
kind of like how I feel as a black
person in general and I had to reel it
back in you know I had my mom cause
she's like oh like what is going on my
brother hit me up and I was like you
know I I took a deep dive into being
angry and that is part of it you know
you should be angry but like how that
doesn't help anything you know being
angry being upset and pointing the
finger because I can't change the past
and neither can anyone else but what we
can change is how we move together as a
culture you know and like all right well
how can i redirect my energy into like
contributing to that because when I have
kids I want them to be able to play with
you guys kids or look up you well you
guys have kids that are gonna be older
to my kids but like at least look up to
them you know yeah that one soon I have
another one on the way you'll they'll be
the same age is I need to but yeah man I
I would love for this moment in time to
be the time that affects that you know
that's why I think like it's a Eifert
personally feel like it's my
responsibility to be like all right I've
got to contribute to this I don't want I
don't I'm not looking for credit or
anything that's just like I just would
never want anyone to feel like how I
felt growing up you know there as a
black kid there's a lot of unwritten
rules on how to operate in society you
know like yes or no sir
walk with your ID with you all
all the time if a cop comes up to you
hands in the clear so they don't see
your doing anything crazy I mean so many
I could go on just about rules that have
been passed down and you don't exactly
know why but you know why you know so
it's it's it's hard as a black man in
this industry in this world to walk
around and not be automatically vilified
and not seem like you're a threat to
someone and that's that's the media you
know that's you know history you know
and that's things that have been passed
down so like it's time for all of us to
change that narrative you have a black
friend do I seem like a threat you know
like you know I mean like I want to yeah
you know I'm working hard to brush up my
skills but I am in like it's you know so
I got a question for you Wes okay so you
know as a content creator as a media guy
you know you you weren't necessarily
your content wasn't necessary
necessarily centered around you know
cultural movements and you know
community organization and all that kind
of stuff so suddenly you know all the
George Floyd protests hid in the black
ice matters black lives matter protests
it and all that kind of stuff and did
you suddenly feel like there's a
pressure on you to somebody have to be a
spokesman for african-american people
and in a person you can put out
statements and you know like something
to pressure yeah I don't feel the
pressure I feel the responsibility I
don't think all my content will be
directed towards that but my content
will be consciously I'll be consciously
aware of the reading the room you know
like I have to be able to read the room
I'm not gonna force it down people's
throat but you know if I'm a consecrated
I'm a creative person how can I just be
creative and do it
without doing you know like that's
that's what I think my contribution is
outwardly internally I'm trying to earn
everything I can about the subject so I
can just I guess like inform myself just
because you know as a human person that
wants to be intellectual like it's just
healthy to know yeah yeah yeah yeah and
you know like your your content isn't
naturally a reflection of who you are
and what you learn and the things that
you want to give back so it's good yeah
I what was that film you said to look at
it was the John Oliver piece John
Oliver's yes yeah the most recent last
week tonight it was it's a half hour
mm-hmm and he very I'm not the biggest
fan of John all I really don't like John
Oliver at all is this worth watching yes
so see this is the thing is because he
he had that whole thing about forgiving
student loan debt and I was like I paid
my student loans they shouldn't forgive
student loan debt you know because
that's you know also the fact that it
could destroy the credit system but
that's another subject so I was like
kind of skeptical but man like very very
concisely and and clearly breaks it down
gets into what is going on with how
police unions have effectively METEC 'td
to a degree that is so extreme officers
that you get these types of cases now
and why that is and then also
acknowledging the the actual pressures
that have been put on police because of
the breakdown of other hotel sorry about
that wait hold on okay yeah the because
of the breakdown of other previously
existent social safety nets like now
while the sudden you know like police
are supposed to solve x y&z not just
like deal with a criminal but now I'll
say you're supposed to do this and
you're supposed to do that
well at the same time like the the
strength of the unionization against the
city to be like doesn't matter what that
officer did you know they're gonna
they're gonna stay and and and those two
things like colliding together yeah
creating this these these issues these
not issues these these murders these
deaths speaking of speaking about the
police having to handle everything so
there is this woman that moved into unit
one of this building a couple years ago
and one day she ended up having like a
full-on like schizophrenic breakdown I
don't remember what the particular is
yes they're still writing on the wall it
says Aaron is a prophet of the nation's
anyways so she just has a full-on
breakdown she's I mean she's fine she's
not violent or anything like that but
she's like loopy she's like starting to
like paint the hallway she's like she's
very much out of control not like she
can't take care of herself
so me and Brett driver happened to be
around and like we talked to her we end
up getting like her sister's number we
call her and she's like we tried
everything I'm not don't call me again
I'm not helping her and we actually
their mom's number two would call her
mom's like yep we tried to help her and
she won't take anything we do so she's
on her own
and I'm like well [ __ ] you guys are yeah
like I get it but guys are still kind of
being [ __ ] family members but okay
whatever so Brett and I trying to figure
out we're talking to her like you know
trying to keep things safe and like like
I guess we should call the police
there's no one else to call call the
police I guess and so the police come
they're like hey you know she's having
an episode like she's not safe here like
we can't leave her here like she she
will probably burn the place down or
something you know like right yeah she's
already demonstrating that like she's
destroying property she's going nuts
like he can't just leave her there cuz
like yeah and so like there's no one
else to come through and like police
like well she's not breaking any laws
like really yeah
all right let's have a little interview
I probably pleading the case octocopter
pulls the notebook and just like
suspends like has she done any physical
threats towards you I'm like no she's
like mm-hmm has she made you fear for
your safety
wink wink like yes she has off a surge
like good and you think she might be
dangerous to herself and others wink
wink like yes she has I feel like I had
to go through hoops just to get the cops
be able to put her into the cop car and
take her to another place where she's
just not on the street running wild
danger to herself and others yeah yeah
and like so I had to like you know you
have to like the cops can't just do it
cuz they you know right and now yeah
there's no one else to do it like you
got is supposed to be here for you know
like like we said in the video there's a
social contract if I do something wrong
do something wrong we be punished for it
that's how that John Oliver video is
it's a woman and it's a video of her and
I think I mean but we need like other
services than just police to fix
everybody yeah
and like you know now you have to put
her into a legal system that's not
suited for supporting her because it's
the only option that's there and it's
just such a bad fit and you can feel it
no I know
yeah well I was this is again they used
to they used to take people like that
and put them in like work to live houses
mmm now obviously those had all kinds of
issues but that was that was how and and
obviously there was a lot less of it
there was less population there was you
know a lot more other sort of safety
nets and people you know the world was
obviously harsh or - back in the day
like you just died I don't know what the
right answer is there but I've always
thought that and I've been doing some
like research on this and I don't know
if this is the right answer but like if
there were some if there was some type
of system that was not Jail and it
wasn't like you know hey just live here
and if we if you want our help we'll
give it to you
something that's completely voluntary
but something that's like somewhere in
the middle you know like it's it's like
you you you you're I don't know if this
person was homeless or whatnot I don't
know if they were they just okay so she
had just had an episode she had a
breakdown yeah but she's like she
literally just let her dog go into the
street like buy so that a series of
those breakdowns could lead to
homelessness yeah oh yes it sucks
because you know at the end of the day
we have to be able to trust each other
yeah and you know there just needs to be
like people have to have a moral compass
and you can't look at you can't I can't
look at you and just assume you have a
good moral compass you know I you can
only do so much of a background check
you know so we're in a very difficult
position as a society yeah you know yeah
especially with like living in major
cities like this - it's like there's so
many people and I can imagine cops being
stressed out like I can imagine you know
the amount of responsibility that they
have but you know just like martial arts
or meditation there's no excuse like it
like the best example I can think of
which I heard the other day is like if
someone works at Starbucks and the
customers upset you do everything you
can to make that customer not upset or
it could be like [ __ ] you and get fired
because you get fired you get fired yeah
and the cops they're literally [ __ ]
people up you know like straight up yeah
and nobody is holding them accountable
like that it's like you teach your kids
if you have something to say to me talk
to me don't hit your brother and sister
yeah it's it's that to me it's that
simple right there and like that is like
something you know is not wired
correctly in order for them to feel like
you know 'but awning a protester with no
weapons or she I seen I seen a cop today
shoot a stun and grenade into this
woman's chest
she was just peacefully present she had
her hands up it was like hey you know we
were here you know peaceful produce yeah
because there isn't probably super
stressed out and a [ __ ] [ __ ] put
together you know yeah so you lose that
and then also the I think what you get
into this is the deeper politics thing
but I'm not gonna get too far into it
but I feel like there there needs the
better a balance of accountability for
law enforcement seems like it's a major
issue right now in the sense of like yes
you I understand we need people to be
bad in the sense of we need cops to be
able to like kick the [ __ ] out of
someone and shoot people like there's a
role for that in a society yeah and some
people are gonna not see the full side
of certain stories when it comes to what
police have to do and they'll get angry
at them in it it'll probably it can be
unjustified sometimes you don't know the
whole story I saw a 10 second clip of
some guy on Twitter getting beat up
turns out he robbed the place turns out
he already punched a cop turns out he's
already like you know fighting people
and yeah we need to see that we only saw
the part or he the punches you know
something yeah there's a lot of cool
element but at the same time it just
seems like for every time I see that I
also still see one of those classic this
guy did not deserve whatever yeah girls
stay on the gun hands on her head and
the cop just comes up and yeah Mace's
are the kicks are it's like easier yeah
yeah and you see that and you're like
well okay
and that cop is just gonna disappear
back into the line of riot police or
even still right gonna go even even if
it's not a riot situation they're gonna
go back to the department and get
reprimanded real quick slap on the hand
yeah well you know you still did this to
another person and it wasn't justified
so like you need to be accountable yeah
that eventually maybe you make a mistake
or two and I get mistakes can come with
the job but that's why they passed the
whole qualified immunity law certain
people make honest mistakes and that
happens but then what happens when you
make two honest mistakes and then three
honest mistakes it's like you're yeah
you're a terrible police officer and put
the promises that unfortunately there's
no there's no balance of accountability
there's no there's no line there's no
line and so
and I feel like that's the main that's
the main thing right now which is like
yes we need police in our society yes we
also need to find a way to balance out
this accountability so that way there's
not the reckless like cavalier attitude
of police officers VK video of a guy
who's smoking a cigarette at a bus stop
in San Diego which is illegal or
something you know and the cops just
like you know basically beat him up and
it's like he's like [ __ ] that law making
smoking legal again I don't give a [ __ ]
don't beat him up like you know it's
like like you're you to use that power
for this situation and and and it's that
kind of accountability of like come on
like there's also the discussion though
like like you know ya don't have a
[ __ ] hard-on for arresting people guys
like like this I mean the system is just
so it's so trash watching Netflix is the
13th where he just kind of goes through
the 13th amendment and you know jail
reform and the cops actually admit like
certain months you know we have to meet
a certain amount of quota a certain
amount of these a certain amount of
these in order for something I don't
know yeah I don't know I don't remember
what this the rest the census was right
but that's the thing like law
enforcement quotas like need to be for
internal review quick only they had
nothing and zero relationship like
opposite experience on duty yeah well
yeah that there's there's a there's a
fundamental disconnect there's no such
thing as speeding ticket quotas there's
no such thing as arrest quotas all
they're supposed to do is monitor and in
interact with people when they're needed
and like like that this is the kind of
like I feel like when we see the
Minneapolis Police Department get
disbanded every was like you're crazy
no police and it's like well if the
police union prevents the reform like
this from happening
it's basically what we're seeing is
hostile takeovers and police departments
and asite you see what happens in
Minneapolis you know what I'm saying
like that's feel like we're in those
positions where it's like it's not like
they're not gonna actually it's not like
the police as a concept or disband
banded all they're doing is basically
saying alright Union you're prevent
from getting like any sort of reform
so we're disbanded no more police cool
so that means we know in India union
contracts gone yeah reform it on the
city's terms with some reforms and then
proceed as usual not like and of course
the of course like you know I find
myself mostly on the like middle
conservative road most of the time but
the Republicans have taken advantage of
that to be in like look what they're
doing they're defunding the cops and
it's like why do you have to just
pointers and likes and just like say
that because that's without without
without like taking a moment and saying
like okay what does this mean exactly
yeah you know this is what this really
mean and this is kind of what I think
we're talking about earlier with the
whole how you discuss politics in this
video you guys made and like that issue
of like wait a second you can't defund
the place it's like wow hold on now
we're already we're arguing like
symptoms at this point you know so to
speak rather than like what is the
fundamental concept that we're
discussing here you know it's it's not
the funding levels of police officers
isn't good I mean it may have direct
correlations on things but like what are
we trying to accomplish here you know
and like maybe maybe the defunding is
reactionary in certain extents yeah if
you want police officers to have more
training which people all laws also are
asking for new funding works against it
you know we also we also see all sorts
of symptomatic issues here people
talking about gun control like crazy
three months ago and now there's a spike
in even left-leaning people right
purchasing firearms like one cops are
not or do you want the second way hold
on
we're guns banned or do you want cops
man we're like both or like yeah all
these symptomatic concepts and specific
action points quote-unquote are
conflicting with each other and so the
moment you start taking these hard
stances on these action points it's like
if you're okay like everyone made fun of
the corporate commercials with kovat 19
a month ago now corporate commercials
are have a new canned message ooh we're
not gonna make fun of that now it's like
hold on you know here's what we're doing
out of Co vid and here's what we're
doing about plaquemines Matt was like we
hold on it's like you thought it was
okay to make fun of it
a month ago where's your funny montage
of it's yeah making fun to come you know
it's this
all these action points start to light
we reset it needs a harder than say and
I like hold on hold on like is Co
mid-nineteen killing more people than
protestors and cops yes like oh [ __ ] I
saw a hilarious headlight yesterday from
the LA Times it said coronavirus spikes
over the weekend more cases seen than in
a month and I went on the LA County
coronavirus number of cases and it was
literally yes there was two dates over
the weekend but the overall trajectory
of the chart was like a nice slow down
they say but this headline is Corona
visors cases spiked and it's like over
what time over the last seven days sure
but it's still lower than it was then
and there's still a downward trajectory
and that's obviously doesn't recognize
like cases go up and down yeah not to
mention you have all the people making
fun of the people protesting lockdowns
now they can't in so the make fun of
protesters then are we making fun of
protesters still you know it's like yeah
and it's like idiots for breaking
quarantine and protesting and it's like
okay now repeat that message come on say
it and then they can't you know it's
like yeah this is this is this issue I
see right now it's like you hop on board
with one of these like no issues on our
symptomatically top Tom now yeah like
the it's I love it in a way though it
because it's just through the biggest
curveball and all these people who like
we're you know conspiracy theorists at
all but I just are founded by feel like
you know there's someone manipulating us
that's me night sorry it's me thank you
finally for a minute it's him guys I
mean everybody knows it come on let's
end this with like a mysterious oh yeah
you're right man I love conspiracy
theories who's the man behind this do
you have more details on this cuz I'm
very confused and if you can make sense
of all this I will
very very happy I'll be yeah I do
enjoyed the black square conspiracy
theory like that way
well that one right there was that one
got cuz I found the original person who
made it you know and it was supposed to
be specifically for like kind of like
the music industry and then you know
through the game of telephone it ended
up having another message yeah well
don't get me wrong it's it totally isn't
a conspiracy it's people think going I
like this this is a cool way to like say
something let me just throw out the
conspiracy okay so disclaimer guys this
is really excited yeah this is a real
conspiracy
this isn't how things actually work but
he was throwing us out there but I could
never we started posting black squares
in the Instagram people were theorizing
that maybe this was a tactic being used
by a group to actually suppress
discussion and to get every to be put
out there well yeah obviously people are
just like hey this is visually striking
it's a good symbol like you know people
latched on to the message because hey
that's how viral things work you can't
control what goes viral but there is a
theory that like you know every blacks
their Instagram for a day maybe wherever
just stops talking about it and loses
some scene I don't have strong
conspiracies alright man none of them
are actually strong all week they're
like Flat Earth [ __ ] like you're not
gonna stand up to scrutiny sorry my
conspiracies man I know they're already
weak the goal at the end day was
supposed to be we stand in solidarity
together so we you know we kind of you
know we post this black thing in support
of black lives matter the problem with
it was if you hashtag blacklivesmatter
it completely disintegrates and destroys
anything that was you know making that
movement progress forward so they
started going around say hey do not have
to hike black lives matter hashtag black
out Tuesday
so it became confusing a lot of people
were like why why would we do a blackout
and then stop talking about the issues
that actually brought things to light
for us you know so then it just it just
became this like what are we doing are
we just following a trend or are we
thinking for ourselves and I found
myself kind of straddling a line I was
like I want to support this black out
but I don't know actually know why I'm
doing it yeah you know I like the idea
of like taking a day to like not be
about social media or anything like that
because you know I love you all do get
caught up in trends and like going to
the protest to take a picture of
yourself you know like I totally get the
idea like okay guys step away from all
the social media [ __ ] and like do
something real you know yeah and I like
the idea that that black out being a
time to like discuss reflect converse
like get off of Instagram and go do
something else
I like that notion behind it but
obviously it's not a controlled thing it
you know everybody's gonna do their own
thing with it and it can mean a million
different things just like you know
every person out of protest is an
individual with their own goals and
thoughts like it's not a single Union
it's not a single company and that's
what the people that are anti protests
like keep trying to they keep trying to
boil it into like one thing once again
that's how human beings work like you
can't see a number greater than three
like when you put like marbles on the
floor like I can put one marble you can
look at back that's one I can put two
marbles thing back that's to act about
three that's three when I put four your
brain goes to two and you recognize it
as four if I put six marbles or eight
marbles you can't just glass in the back
that's eight marbles you brain a spec
group Group group group so conceptually
as human beings in our biology yeah so
when we get like a thousand people it's
like those aren't a thousand individuals
that's one group of people that's one
thing it's a mob you know it's like it's
not a thousand people with a thousand
different stories a thousand different
lives that's too much to consider our
brain yeah that's true you know dude I
catch myself doing that I think if
everybody was a little bit more aware of
that of just like lumping people
together yeah
that's a good that's a good one be a
good thing to get away from well well
his is that it is that it you had a
conspiracy theory you were gonna go
oh no I've my conspiracy theories
coronavirus oh that's subscribe to hear
that one maybe we should start us
conspiracy theories only podcast I don't
I don't I think I think we already talk
about conspiracy theories and almost
every pop guy speaking hold on let me
just don't like this one get ready I
don't like this one okay would all the
politicians in Washington we have all
the Senate all these Congress people and
look at the age of all the people in
charge okay they're all right in that
susceptible right in that susceptible
thing yeah and they have power and Cova
19 is the boomer remover okay I'm just
saying people are shut down there people
in who have the power to shut down the
country are doing it for somewhat
selfish means because they're not
targeting people who are affected by it
they're not targeting people who are
like susceptible to it in a in a in any
specific way and they're just saying
flip the switch
lights out because before he told latch
on that conspiracy too hard it's still
horrible when old people just die from
it deserves everybody it's not okay for
65 year old no I'm not no you're not I
just think that I'll duper like you're
right yeah [ __ ] that it's like no guys
guys guys yeah it's okay I don't want
them to get it and suffer horrible fate
yes we all do you know as we all know
people who could be so you don't want to
lose so it's like if we had to take the
County for a couple months who save a
hundred thousand lives and all those
hundred thousand lives happened to be 65
and older
it's still worth doing yeah you know at
that point yes at that point yes but a
million you know you know what guys I
had to say it I want to do this for
podcast I want to value a human life
all right not this podcast I want in
this can be a out there discussion I
want to sit down back if you were to try
to evaluate human life because you know
what there's a minimum wage multiply
that by the number of hours a person
lives is that the value of a human life
next time on the court okay apparently
actually Wow all right so all right love
you guys thanks for listening this is a
yeah guys yeah no this is a free speech
zone and a good conversation alright and
remember like Nico said we can always
change your opinions yes yeah never we
want we can chase you right wrong or
back and back again
mm-hmm so you know is here like
exploring with each other try to and
sometimes laugh sometimes you say for
the last like I kind of did there a
little bit just know know where that
nowhere that no one we start getting a
little edgy it's usually just for the
laughs and the fun what is yeah how else
do you invent like cool alien stuff we
can practice this on the next one okay
all right next time on corridor cast
conspiracy theories and we value a human
life and we all take a bottle of water
that was drank by a Copa nineteen
patient and I'll take small sips for me
see he gets symptoms first few films to
check out for any listeners out there
that want to do more research on the
subject I'd highly suggest the 13th
melanin code he bro Sony grows and he's
Hebrews he grows yeah that was a really
good one and the last one that I watched
was I think it's called hidden secrets
by Tariq nasheed so like just to kind of
give you context of history and also
black history is it too old it's like
throwing American History X into that
list no I think no it's a good dramatic
expose I think how white young men can
get sucked into that life it's a good
changing the process of changing your
mind story yes very much
even thrown out there what is it I
listen to a podcast the Joe Rogan
podcast with Darrell Davis really really
really good
really cool jazz musician who converted
like 200 Klu Klux Klan members nice took
the ropes yeah it's pretty incredible
really good really good story Thanks
well guys I love you guys but I don't
work in here with you guys and I
appreciate you guys being empathetic to
addressing the elephant in the room you
bet man likewise I appreciate you uh
really appreciate you taking the time to
talk with us and that girl impatient
with discussions on it and yeah just
share thoughts and viewpoints yeah it's
very valuable agreed all right all right
cool well see in the next podcast
everybody